let's talk about healthcare really weird
thing yesterday we heard there would be
a vote in the Senate about Obamacare or
the Affordable Care Act repeal or the
American Health Care Act but we didn't
know what was going to be voted on tons
of reports yesterday in the afternoon
saying hey Republicans have moved ahead
on repealing Obamacare not exactly true
Republicans with Vice President Mike
Pence as the tie-breaking vote in the
Senate voted to start debating a bill
which includes a possible Obamacare
repeal John McCain who was recently
diagnosed with brain cancer showed up to
a standing ovation cast his vote in
favor of starting debate on an Obamacare
repeal then spoke and said as it stands
right now I wouldn't actually vote for
the bills that have been proposed but I
do believe that we should start debate
on this the good news so far is what
well Republicans still lack 50 votes on
any particular major policy plan and
they lack 60 votes on the parts of
Obamacare that require 60 votes in order
to repeal Democrats and Republicans
immediately moved on from this vote and
went on to vote on one particular
amendment and that already failed 57 to
43 in favor but again that was one that
needed 60 votes in favor in order to
pass here's what we can expect and some
of this is happening right now pass so
by the time people watch the show either
later tonight on free speech TV or by
the time you go to the gym and get on
the treadmill like many of you do and
start listening to the episode some of
these amendments may already have been
voted on but here's some of what's going
to be happening one the better care Rik
reconciliation act this is one of the
primary Republican legislations that
would get rid of a lot of the Obamacare
policies including a penalty for people
who don't have health insurance it would
cut subsidies it would put in a
different type of tax credit this one
would be a total disaster just wouldn't
work it's already been scored and the
Medicaid expansion would already would
also be phased out as part of this
amendment total and utter train wreck
there's the Cruz amendment this is a Ted
Cruz amendment which would basically
allow insurance come
Bennie's to totally ignore the obamacare
rules it wouldn't change those rules but
it would allow insurance companies to
ignore the Obamacare rules for plans for
individuals or small businesses that's
the type of plan I'm on for example it
would allow them to bail on covering
maternity they could bail on covering
mental health treatment in all but one
of their plans the rule would be you
have to have one plan that covers those
things it can cost whatever it is they
want to charge forget about Democrats
even Republicans don't like that
amendment so that one is unlikely to
pass we've got the Portman amendment
senator Rob Portman actually has to
think about all the people in his state
of Ohio that benefited from the Medicaid
expansion so his idea is for people who
are currently on Medicaid tax credits
I'm sorry for people who are currently
unmedicated we will create a hundred
billion dollar fund to give them tax
credits so that they can buy their own
insurance if they switch out of Medicaid
then you've got a straight repeal only
bill Senator Rand Paul likes that one we
were listening to him earlier pat on the
floor of the Senate talking about that
repeal period he's been against many of
the proposed substitutes to Obamacare
because he believes it still contains a
lot of parts of Obamacare he wants to go
with the whole thing and then most
recently we've heard about this skinny
repeal that the new popular phrase and
it's not the latest it's not going to be
the result of the latest weight loss
plan or diet what that means is you get
rid of three Obamacare provisions you
get rid of the individual mandate you
get rid of the employer insurance
mandate and you get rid of the tax on
medical device manufacturers the problem
is if you get rid of that and keep other
stuff you can no longer pay for the
other stuff in other words these are
some of the provisions that enable those
other things to be funded right I mean
hearing all these different proposals it
just sounds as if Senate Republicans are
trying to pass something anything
because then you can move it to the next
step which is conference and you can
join it together in some way with the
the version of the House pass which is
the afford of the American Health Care
Act that we
all thought was dead yeah and what this
also allows them to do is to go home to
their constituents during the August
recess say we did say we move to start
debate on Affordable Care Act we did
something right we did something and
they can't go back and have to explain
wait a second Trump said on day one he
was going to start working on this and
you've done nothing the real situation
here is these people are never going to
solve the health care problem we would
only have new problems created by the
quote solutions that have been proposed
so far we will track it we're covering
this closely it will affect could
potentially kick 10% of the country's
population off of health insurance the
video you just watched was made possible
by support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad